president Trump blasting Speaker Nancy
Pelosi just moments ago for canceling
the State of the Union he was planning
to deliver in the House chamber on
Tuesday the State of the Union speech
has been canceled by Nancy Pelosi
because she doesn't want to get the
truth she doesn't want the American
public to hear what's going on and she's
afraid of the truth we were planning on
doing a really very important speech in
front of the House and the Senate
Supreme Court so we just found out that
she's cancelled and I think that's a
great blotch on the incredible country
that we all love she blames security but
she knew it wasn't a security problem
but I just got back from Iraq I was very
safe in Iraq and I felt very safe we had
great great security if we can handle
Iraq we can handle the middle of
Washington will do something in the
alternative we'll be talking to you
about that at a later date but what
she's doing to the American people what
she's doing to our Constitution is it
just grace what was that movie Greg you
can't handle the truth
yes Jerry Maguire I'm kidding I know I'm
joking are you asking me a question no
I'm just ting you up so oh I mixed that
as you know I'm ecstatic this is all
coming together I didn't want to go to
DC DC is like the worst ride in
America's amusement park there's no fun
in DC just walking tours walking tours
it's the most overrated capital in
America and I include Sacramento in that
this is another thing your Thank You
Donald Trump that he is disrupted and
and and gotten off our plate things that
last year was a Correspondents Dinner we
didn't need that we don't miss it we're
not gonna miss the State of the Union he
should do it skywriting that's my guy
right
the his State of the Union or he should
do it in a Twitter thread that's easy
too but you don't need this this stupid
pop and circum in circumstance thank you
wait the skywriting say build the wall
and crime will fall yes exactly and then
and then we're done but I mean he's
gotten rid of
he's gotten rid of the Correspondents
Dinner State of the Union
I think you should get rid of stubborn
belly fat and embarrassing back fat
those diarrhea pills that come in the
little pot parts that you can't open get
rid of that tmv get rid of that we're
done what is team DMV DMV this is a big
block he's never happened before and
he's checked it out and I don't know if
it has he's saying that he was safe in
Iraq when he went during the shutdown
why can't DC be justice it well I I
always thought that Nancy Pelosi had a
stronger argument saying we're not doing
the State of the Union until the
government's back open but you and I'll
work on a date for when the government's
back open we'll invite you down and
she's still kind of saying that but when
her first law her first letter said
please come give a State of the Union on
January 29th the second one said I think
it would not be a good idea because of
security concerns and he's right that
was lame there the security concerns are
not real I think she would have been
even stronger at that point to be able
to say no we're not doing this until the
government's reopen these people deserve
to be paid for the work they're doing so
when that's done you can come back and
he/she sent the first letter during the
shutdown long so the president's saying
well why are you using this as an excuse
when you invited me during the shutdown
in the beginning well I I don't buy the
security thing at all but I mean clearly
what's going on here is the government's
not functioning there are real issues at
play I mean you you stop and look at
it's not only the I think it's 800,000
not being paid the contractors today we
heard about IRS agents who are not
reporting but getting passes they can go
out and get you know small jobs that
help pay the bills FBI says child
trafficking terror investigations are
being impeded according to the FBI Union
the airports we know about the Coast
Guard we know about you know to me this
is a real problem it's even the State
Department says they were gonna have a
conference on border security they can't
have that
so we're mean this is a you know Senator
Mark Warner said stop stupidity stop
inflicting shutdown transferring
unnecessary pain and inflicting damage
and you see this in the polls 71 percent
of Americans say this wall is not worth
this shutdown this is hurting the
country but I think you know essentially
it's hurting President Trump well it's
not worth it you should be thrilled our
country's in this place if all that
stuff's happening though that you just
laid out why don't Democrats just get on
board and support all the stuff that
they supported years ago that he's
proposing I mean they all are on record
as having supported not only the board
of security measures but now they're
having to say no to no we don't want
humanitarian aid no we don't want relief
for TPS and daca recipients just because
Trump proposed it I mean I agree that
having all of these things stagnant is
bad but what he put forward was
something that was completely palatable
and you know I think Nancy Pelosi she's
a spiteful one sometimes she is and she
is and she didn't want Trump to come out
I don't love the State of the Union I
agree with Greg I think it's boring I
think they somehow make presidents for
some reason to look like monarchs in
that moment it's painful to watch
but it is an opportunity to get out
there and have a lot of people tune into
something who typically wouldn't tune in
and I don't think she wanted president
Trump talking about the aspects of crime
and and the fact that he put forth
something that had the doctor relief
that had the TPS relief so that voters
in the middle could say wait a minute he
did put something forth that could have
been palatable close why isn't she
biting he gave the prime time address
laying out all those things except for
the stuff that he offered on Saturday
yeah and it didn't move the needle at
all but I think against her so I think
that if she if she's just being
politically smart I mean I'm not saying
that it's like good policy but you've
been politically smart like why would
you move that's true but I know a lot of
people that tune in like I watch the
news all the time we watch news all the
time but I know a lot of people that
don't watch media so when it says State
of the Union no choices on every channel
it is it's disgusting you could read a
book if you want but I think a lot of
people do read books but I won't say
this to you that when you see this
argument about crime in the wall that
the president was tweeting about today
it is so fallacious I mean the
statistics say that crime in fact
violent crime has been down over the
last 20 years even as we've seen the
increase in illegal immigrants why
haven't Christ been calling any of
manatorian crisis
when they didn't have a wall in El Paso
there was a lot of violent crime they
put the wall up and the crime let's
listen to what Chuck had to say about
this whole hostage taking scenario or
not president's proposal is just
wrapping paper on the same partisan
package in hostage taking taxes hostage
taking should not work it's very hard to
negotiate when a gun is held to your
head the American people know that
President Trump is responsible for the
shutdown and now they have learned that
leader McConnell is a co-conspirator all
right and the president actually called
Chuck Schumer a puppet of Pelosi so it
looks like he's trying to drive a wedge
between the two leaders uses an analogy
though we have been an Americans have
been held hostage by career politicians
who are making ice living off this
prison of two ideas they need us to be
polarized on immigration they need you
to think that having a wall means you
don't like people from Mexico they need
that argument cuz that keeps them in
power
there has to be a way of breaking out of
this prison because you can't be Pro
refugee refugee but also think maybe you
should limit you should limit
merit-based immigration
I'm actually more inclined to go with
refugees than merit-based because
refugees are more grateful so that but
you can you can actually have a
compromise or get out of this prison you
know I think that breath when refugees
come here they they make really make
great citizens but you have to extreme
vet see the compromise here is having a
number of tools in that shed it's not
just this or this it's a if that's the
prison you've got to find all these
others lot of different clubs in the bag
but yet exactly because that's what the
Democrats is saying we can have right so
where are the Democrats they have come
forward but guess what McConnell won't
bring that before word now he's gonna
have because the president won't sign it
yeah that's the exactly so this is like
a trap you know it's like you can't get
out of the trap and poor President Crump
he's stuck in this draft waiting for the
far
French to give him permission slip to
make I'm glad you feel sorry for the
president was very compassionate thank
you